[Music]
now
to move not beyond meat but move on with
the debate i cut up on carol adams to
conclude the side proposition
[Applause]
i've read the motion and i believe we
should move beyond all meat
so
what we choose to eat has consequences
far beyond the circumference of our
plates
specifically your vote tonight
expresses your allegiance to or
rejection of a white supremacist
patriarchal worldview
do we vote to further inequality and
sustain world-destroying violence
in the sexual politics of meat i
introduced the concept of animals as
absent reference
in order to be eaten animals must
disappear as living beings that is be
killed
they then disappear conceptually as so
many forms in which we eat animals
corpses are massaged by euphemistic
language hamburger steak pork bacon etc
even the speaker just before me talked
about turkeys he's talking about dead
butchered turkeys of whom part of their
bodies will be eaten
meat eaters ordered leg of lamb not a
baby lamb's leg
the animals cannot possess their own
body parts
tonight think about how the language of
our debate has or has not participated
in the structure of the absent referent
who disappears and why
21st century animal eating requires our
complicity in a new colonialism
we know how settler colonialism worked
and a race and replace system that
forced indigenous people off the land
replacing them with cattle and white
settlers
i recognize today as indigenous peoples
day
one of the defining aspects of the
colonial legacy is an ongoing white
supremacist belief system and an
ownership paradigm
when you own the land you get the title
to it
entitlement and ownership are linked
all the justifications for the taking of
land by white colonial authorities
included the claim well the indians
can't prove they own the land
hunting exists within this colonial
ownership paradigm
it presumes that animals don't have
title to their own lives
once dispossessed of their lives the
hunted animal can become your property
uh in a minute approximately 90 of
native americans were killed off by
erase and replace settler colonialism
it's the new colonialism that boasts
i'll hunt for myself and be grateful
like the native americans as well like
the native americans i thank the animal
for their sacrifice
and i wonder how do you know the animal
would have picked you to feed off their
corpse
the argument that hunting is ethical
presumes that some primeval form of
eating exists unmediated by corrupting
influences of society
there's no room in the new colonialism
for an indigenous worldview to exist
instead it collapses more than a hundred
native american nations into one amalgam
and attributes a static indigenous world
view that erases those nations that were
predominantly vegetarian and lived in
urban areas
the new colonialists see nothing wrong
with a pick and choose approach to
indigenous thought that never engages
with the survival issues indigenous
peoples are facing today
seventy percent of the population would
have to be eliminated for people to try
to rely on hunting to survive
who would live and who dies and who
decides
as for domesticated animals percy
shelley pointed out just after being
expelled from oxford
the quantity of nutritious vegetable
matter consumed in fattening the carcass
of an ox
would afford ten times the sustenance if
gathered immediately from the bosom of
the earth
two hundred years after shelley as we as
we've heard
one third of the landmass of the world
is committed to animal agriculture
entire ecosystems are disappearing
80 percent of deforested acres in the
amazon were cleared for animal-based
cattle grazing and yet tonight at dinner
i saw the lions eaters send meat back
from their plates
so-called free-range animals contribute
more greenhouse gases while killing them
in mobile slaughterhouses requires more
water than industrial slaughterhouses
and leaves behind an immense amount of
waste requiring an intense amount of
chemicals in the process
your meat may be organic but your
slaughtering isn't
if you eat animals you take up more
climate space requiring more water more
land more forest deforestation
contributing more greenhouse gases
this is felt disfortunately by countries
in the global south
their carbon footprint is smaller but
they experience more frequent and
intense climate change caused weather
events
these events especially affect girls and
young women
your hamburger comes with a dose of
misogyny
the western world colonized their space
without sending a single beef eater
through colonial power the diet of beef
loving english people became normative
the food heritage of pre-conquest
peoples like the land itself was overrun
it was the colonizers especially the
british who declared that the virility
of meat-eating nations explained their
success over the supposed feminine and
weak rice-eating countries that
they defeated
historically the vast majority of the
world lived without animal protein as a
central part of their diet
the assumption that the best protein
comes from corpses is a racist belief as
it erases and replaces indigenous
african asian mesoamerican cultural food
practices
meat eating is also one of the ways
gender-based structures of oppression
are perpetuated
men in the west are taunted to renew
their man card by eating meat because
that's what real men do
that's the sexual politics of meat and
it reveals how unsettled masculinity
really is
back home my library card is good for
seven years
but a man card can expire between
breakfast and lunch if someone eats a
veggie burger
masculinity a construct of the gender
binary facing constant destabilization
feels always under threat and eating
animals is its protection racket
the question that's why after 9 11.
nope
that's why after 9 11
a focus on men as heroes and on meat
eating became part of the reclamation of
a wounded masculinity
when a black man was elected as u.s
president we saw how white this wounded
masculinity was
white supremacist weapon weaponized
eating meat eggs and dairy
images of milk drinking white men of
platters groaning with meat
and the baiting of liberal men as
so-called soy boys are all part of the
neo-nazi
messaging
[Applause]
this is their right the neo-nazis say
this is their identity
the new colonization rests on the
unstable foundation of white men's
insecurities
look at the way people
men in the animal industry speak of
female animals as willing and ready to
be made forcibly pregnant
which female animals are powerless to
resist
that be no meat eating without the
constant forced reproduction
by female animals
yet popular culture is flooded with
references to sexy cows sexy pigs sexy
chickens
sexy fishes
who all just want to have fun
they want to be pregnant and they want
to be killed because this feminized
sexuality wants to be eaten
the only desire animals are credited
with possessing is the desire to be
consumed
which strangely can only be expressed
after their death
real life tells a different story
animals try to escape from
slaughterhouses or farms when able cows
try to reclaim their calves
taken from them so their nursing
material can be monetized and sold to
humans
they fight and resist the faith the
colonial empire claims is their welcomed
destiny
some meat eaters are afraid of what they
will feel if they look too closely at
the degradations that constitute animals
experience
mention disabling practices are the
devastating separation of cows and their
babies and we hear meat eaters exclaim
don't tell me
why are they afraid of the feelings such
knowledge produces
they accept a patriarchal construct that
views feelings as unruly and
untrustworthy causing chaos
to say you care about animals is
considered a sign of weakness in a world
still committed to the gender binary
that values stereotyped masculine reason
over stereotyped feminine feeling and
wants order
and yet the reasons we hear are so
irrational
if i did not eat animals they never
would be born
meat eaters like anti-abortionists have
forgotten that one quality of
non-existence is not having awareness
about existence
meat eaters say why if we put prisoners
to work in slaughterhouses in england
they will be learning a skill
i did not know that killing was a skill
generalizable to other jobs
the new colonialists boast i only eat
meat from locally owned farms and i know
the farmers there love their animals
if killing what one loves is standard
practice i hope they don't start loving
me
what about carrots
what about carrots were asked though
i've never seen a meat eater leap into
the road to save a carrot from being run
over by an automobile
when all else fails meat eaters assert
that animals are not our equals
one would think such inequality would
require us to respond more not less
sympathetically
meat eaters tell me it's so hard to
change and yet i watch them work even
harder not to change
if you all agree that 95
of meat is from factory farmed animals
and it's wrong
stop eating it go to your colleges and
eat the vegan option which every college
at this campus
offers
it's very simple if you agree with the
basic things so that we're not even
debating factory farms then act on it
so is our global outcome to be
determined by people afraid to change
we're gonna hold on to
some old
conceived notion of power
change may be hard but not changing is
harder
tonight you're being asked to vote on
whether you accept this new colonialism
or not
our menu choices don't stay on the plate
and i heard all your laughter i know
some of these must be new ideas or you
think they're fringe or whatever
our whiteness is part of the problem of
meat eating
it really is so
your vote tonight is important but even
more important is the question of what
or who will be on your plate in the
morning
sweet dreams